attention prépare toi bien apprêtée
leçon la veille
relis ton texte avant d'y aller ok ok
tout ça ce sont de très bons conseils
très utiles pour réussir à prendre
avancée mais moi je pense que c'est très
utile aussi de savoir improviser
parce que savoir improviser c'est savoir
prendre des risques le risque de donner
une réponse inattendue parce qu'on l'a
pas préparé le risque de s'exprimer de
façon originale parce que on a été pris
de court et puis savoir improviser c'est
aussi savoir rebondir rebondir après
s'être trompé rebondir après avoir déplu
à quelqu'un c'est à dire rebondir après
ce qu'il est communément appelé un échec
attendez moi bien je suis pas en train
de vous dire que pour réussir ce qu'on
entreprend il ne faut pas travailler et
simplement multiplier les expériences
non je ne le pense pas je pense même
tout le contraire
avant de pouvoir sortir des sentiers
battus il faut d'abord bien connaître
les itinéraires balisés avant d'inventer
une forme nouvelle
il faut longtemps répété les gestes qui
ont fait leurs preuves
je suis pas non plus en train de vous
dire que pour inventer il faut
systématiquement se mettre en danger
surtout si c'est pour fuir la réalité sa
demande souvent plus de courage
d'affronter la réalité que de la fuir
surtout si on se rend compte qu'on n'est
pas forcément conforme au plus grand
nombre et que ça va demander un effort
de faire sa place
faire sa place est souvent plus
difficile que d'en recevoir une
mais c'est plus intéressant aussi pour
illustrer mon propos je vais prendre un
exemple tiré de mon expérience
personnelle
l'entreprise que je que je dirige
aujourd'hui théâtre à la carte
au début c'était une improvisation
aujourd'hui c'est une entreprise qui
donne du travail à plus de 100 personnes
des comédiens des formats
heures des consultants qui intervient
sur les 5 continents dans toutes les
langues ou presque et pourtant au début
ce n'était pas gagné
c'était pas gagné parce que théâtre et
entreprises
voilà deux mots deux mondes qu'on n'a
pas condamné mans envie d'associer et
pourtant qui marche très bien ensemble
ça marche parce que nous n'utilisons pas
les savoir faire et les talents des
artistes pour faire de l'art dans
l'entreprise pour transformer chaque
salarié en artiste non nous les
utilisons ses talents ses savoir faire
pour libérer la parole pour débloquer
des situations parfois conflictuelles
pour faire avancer pour faire évoluer
les comportements professionnels
bref grâce au théâtre nous faisons du
management mais une forme de management
qui redonnent toute son importance à la
dimension humaine et puis ça marche
aussi parce que les entreprises
aujourd'hui s'appuient de plus en plus
sur des procédures stéréotypé des normes
mondialisé qui les rassure
mais dans le même temps elles veulent
paradoxalement s'en émanciper parce
qu'elle se rende compte qu'elle manque
de créativité
alors nous leur proposons grâce à une
forme de pédagogie inverser une solution
originale aller chercher au plus profond
de soi des ressources dont on n'a pas
idée et s'en servir pour avancer
c'est à dire que nous redonnons de
l'importance à ce principe fondamental
de tout apprentissage réussi la
confiance apprendre à improviser
c'est utile pour accepter les chèques et
rebondir avec audace alors comment est
ce qu'on apprend à improviser
eh bien il faut travailler ce qu'on
appelle les piliers de l'improvisation
qui sont au nombre de cinq
je vais vous en présenter trois
l'acceptation
la prise de liddes et le lâcher prise et
je vais essayer de vous montrer que ce
sont aussi trois compétences très utile
dans le monde professionnel
tout d'abord l'acceptation ce qui est
naturel chez l'homme c'est le refus
c'est instinctif c'est une forme d'auto
protection une force d'inertie face au
changement et à tout ce qui est
différent de moi et de mes opinions
en revanche l'acceptation demande un
effort elle n'est pas naturelle
c'est la raison pour laquelle c'est
utile de travailler sa faculté
d'accepter l'autre et bien une bonne
improvisation une improvisation
théâtrale réussie c'est celle qui en
tout premier lieu est fondé sur
l'acceptation des propositions de ses
partenaires parce que si on les refuse
l'improvisation bloc et elle tombe tout
de suite dans une impasse dans le monde
professionnel cette compétence est
fondamental lorsqu'il ya du travail en
équipe
il faut percevoir cectek les différentes
parties prenantes comme partenaire
plutôt que comme des ennemis ou des
concurrents
la prise de l'ide maintenant un leader
c'est celui ou celle qui sait fédérer un
groupe et le mettre en mouvement dans
une même direction est bien dans une
improvisation théâtrale l'improvisateur
alterne constamment entre la posture de
celui qui mène qui donne l'impulsion et
la posture de celui qui reçoit les
impulsions de son ou de sa partenaire et
qui s'y adaptent
et donc on apprend que avoir du
leadership c'est quelque chose de
momentanée c'est une posture qu'il est
parfois utile d'avoir d'autres fois nous
et c'est très utile dans un contexte
professionnel lorsqu'il s'agit
d'organiser un groupe et de lui donner
une impulsion ça débouche sur des
comportement proactif des prises
d'initiatives bref du leadership
managériale voyons enfin le lâcher prise
être créatif ce n'est pas réservé aux
artistes tout le monde je crois peut
l'être
il suffit d'être décontracté de se faire
confiance et de laisser venir les choses
dans une improvisation c'est fondamental
parce qu'il s'agit de créer une histoire
à partir de rien dans un contexte
professionnel
c'est très utile pour sortir des
situations où on a l'impression de faire
du surplace il faut à ce moment-là
trouver des initiatives créer des
alternatives
bref sortir du cadre avec ses trois
compétences
j'ai essayé de vous montrer
qu'improviser c'est très professionnel
parce que ça nous oblige à considérer
les chèques et l'inconnu non pas comme
une sanction ou un danger mais comme des
leviers grâce auquel on peut se
développer
et puis j'espère aussi vous avoir donné
avec le théâtre d'entreprise l'exemple
d'un nouveau métier
créé à partir d'une improvisation qui a
réussi des métiers nouveaux qui reste à
créer il y en a plein et pas seulement
pour les geeks et les passionnés
d'informatique
alors pensons ici